[Music]
hi mysteryrecaft here today i am going
to explain an episode called the rank
from the time mystery thriller series
called girl from nowhere spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
the movie begins in an all-girls high
school in thailand that is different
from ordinary schools because it values
beauty more than it values education in
the opening scene the director of the
school announces that the finals of the
annual shining star competition will be
held soon the top 10 beautiful girls of
the school will be awarded among whom
one will be named the shining star of
the year the only category the students
need to exceed in in order to get the
award is beauty the director claims that
the winner will receive an honorary
trophy as well as a special prize along
with several other privileges throughout
the rest of the year the top 10
contestants will also receive
extraordinary privileges she ends the
announcement by saying that there are no
ugly people in the world just lazy ones
a new student nano is in front of the
school when a thin leaf falls on her and
makes a tiny cut on her cheek she
doesn't flinch or look surprised almost
as if she had been expecting it but with
the scar on her face she can hardly be
the winner of the beauty competition in
the following scene we are introduced to
one of the popular girls named ying she
is currently ranked in the 10th position
on the beauty chart and is famously
known as princess 10. as she walks
through the hallways her classmates try
to snap a picture of her to admire her
beauty the new girl nano enters the
classroom and is made to sit beside ying
by the teacher ying is also the class
leader so the teacher wants her to help
nano catch up with the others ying
happily welcomes the new girl to the
seat beside her but it isn't clear if
she genuinely wants to be nano's friend
or considers her an enemy nano is just
as beautiful as ying if not even
prettier which is clearly making yang
uncomfortable her face glows in
happiness when she sees the scar on
nana's face
to act sympathetic she asks her what
happened nano tries to dismiss the
matter but ying claims that in their
school they must take good care of
themselves and a scar on the face is a
huge problem their conversation is
interrupted when the teacher asks them
to keep quiet after the class ying
brings nano to the top 10 tower it is a
building exclusive to the girls who are
on the top 10 beauty list the tower
provides them with tasty food expensive
makeup a never-ending list of reasons to
remain vain and useless and a luxurious
lifestyle that ordinary students are not
privileged with every student has a rank
in the beauty list that is updated in
real time if anyone's face loses its
beauty their rank drops immediately they
all have an application that shows the
ranks of all students since a top 10 can
bring one friend inside the tower ying
asks nano to come with her nano is
fascinated by the luxurious interior
they eat a wonderful lunch while talking
about several things nano thanks ying
for providing her with such a great
opportunity to be her friend however
ying's intention is not as good as she
thinks it is she boasts about her
lifestyle as a top 10 and claims that if
nana wasn't her friend she would have to
eat with ordinary people in the school
cafeteria nano compliments her
commenting that she is very down to
earth which couldn't be further away
from the truth in reality ying will do
anything to stay in the top 10 and can
hardly survive outside after the meal
nano brings out a bar of chocolate and
starts to eat it ying looks at the
chocolate wanting to try it but scared
of gaining weight when nano insists she
takes a small bite of it following that
a girl named champu approaches ying
calling her princess ten she has been
ying's minion for the past few years
before nano ying used to bring her to
the tower as her friend so champu is
hurt when she sees them together to make
her feel better ying hands her a piece
of cake the workers drag champu out
because she isn't allowed to step inside
the tower without a friend after she is
out ying says that she feels bad for
champu because she has an ugly nose and
a big forehead nano eyes ying knowing
very well that she deems other people
inferior to her because she is prettier
just then the bell rings notifying them
that the number one on the beauty list
and the queen of the school gade has
arrived they welcome her like an actual
queen as she descends from the stairs
ying introduces the rest of the
beautiful girls to nano to make yang
feel better about herself nano comments
that she is as beautiful as gade so she
deserves to be this year's queen ying
then urges her to scan her face on the
app and see what rank she's in but her
face drops when the app says nano is in
11th place she is surprised to see her
new friend is also her biggest
competition ying congratulates nano but
worry is evident on her face
when she leaves we see nano looking at
her smugly she knows that ying is
pretending to be a good person she has
only befriended her to teach her a
lesson the following day is the worst
one for yang because she wakes up with a
large pimple on her nose she is then
informed by the app that she has dropped
to the 11th position because of the
pimple nano has taken her place in the
top 10 beauty list she pops the pimple
which makes it even worse at school the
girls who once used to follow her around
for a picture now start to make fun of
her red nose ying's day only gets worse
when she sees that her minions have
surrounded nano and are praising her
beauty when she walks in everyone goes
silent to add to her misery nano calls
her princess ten ying laughs it off
trying to make it seem like she doesn't
care about the ranking but she is
visibly jealous when she sees nano
wearing a bow that is exclusive to the
top 10 girls a girl asks her if she had
just eaten sweet stuff for her to get
the pimple just then ying remembers the
chocolate nano had given her she starts
to suspect her for deliberately feeding
her sweets so she would get a pimple
during the lunch break ying walks into
the top 10 tower out of habit but the
workers ask her to get out nana tries to
help her saying that she can be her plus
one but the former princess 10 says she
misses the cafeteria's food and leaves
however after eating the first bite of
the food from there she almost chokes
the other students laugh at her reaction
to their peasant food making her feel
worse she then goes to the public
washroom which is even worse still she
places toilet paper on the floor to step
inside but has to run out midway when a
lizard falls to the ground near her a
lizard suffice it to say that she is
miserable outside the luxury of the top
10 tower she is looking for cosmetic
procedures in a magazine when one of her
former minions tells her that she is now
in the sixth position of the top 10 list
ying is left speechless everyone she
thought was lesser than she is is now
getting on the list she runs away crying
at the thought of no longer being
beautiful the following day she dreams
of winning the shining star award but
the director screams after looking at
her acne-filled face she wakes up
panting from the nightmare and notices
that her rank has dropped to number 21.
her face has two more pimples which
means she won't be getting back on the
list anytime soon she goes to the school
with a face mask on and stares at the
top 10 tower longingly later we see her
at the pharmacy looking for medicine to
treat her acne she meets nano there and
runs away embarrassed of her face
outside the shop she bumps into shampoo
but doesn't talk to her nano whispers
something in champu's ear planning
something else for yang's downfall the
following morning ying wakes up to see
her acne has cleared up completely
thanks to the medication she squeals in
happiness when she notices she is back
to being number 10 on the list she is
overly jolly at school which even her
friends think is weird she asks one of
her minions to play swing with her but
she declines instead the girl shows her
the new ranking which says she is still
at number 11. ying is once again
devastated nano tries to make her feel
better and asks her to join her in the
swing however ying has different plans
she has had enough of playing it safe
hence to get a position in the list she
pushes nano off the swing the poor girl
falls face first and bruises her eyes
because of this she drops from the
ranking and yin gets back to being
princess 10. she then snatches nano's
bow tie and walks inside the tower
without even bothering to pick her
friend up but as soon as she leaves nano
opens her eyes as if she had already
planned this out inside the tower the
top 10 girls do not notice ying on the
sofa and start to talk badly about her
they make fun of her for being number 10
her entire life queen gade claims that
ying's mother's jeans are to blame for
her failure in life the girls laugh
while ying listens to them and burns
with anger after they leave she decides
to take revenge on all of them and
become the next shining star she
executes her plan that very day first
she attacks the girl in sixth position
with a wild cat that scratches her face
then she puts ants on the towel that two
of the girls use on their faces by the
third time she grows impatient she
knocks a girl unconscious and trims her
hair and eyebrows for the girls in
second and third positions she mixes a
chemical in their drinks which gives
them hairy faces now the only person she
has to defeat is gade she mixes
permanent dye with a face cream which
makes gade's face turn green since the
ranks are changing so much the top
beauty app glitches the following day
ying comes to school and sees no one
around the trash from the previous days
hasn't been cleaned and the top 10 tower
is also in bad condition she walks in
and sees nano inside it turns out that
since most of the top 10 girls have
dropped to the bottom of the list even
with a bruised face nano is in third
position as they talk gade walks down
the stairs with makeup to cover up her
green face ying is left speechless she
doesn't want to go back to being just a
tenth place after having done so much to
be the shining star gade makes fun of
her claiming that someone like her
doesn't have what it takes to be a star
jangro's furious and attacks gade the
two get into a fight in which both of
their faces are ruined gade's makeup is
removed while yin gets bruises and bite
marks on her after knocking gate out
ying runs to the auditorium where the
new shining star is being announced
after some time the much awaited shining
star winner is announced to be a girl
that no one has ever seen
yang retaliates and asks for a
reevaluation because the winner doesn't
even go to their school only then it is
revealed that the winner is champoo who
has had a huge glow up she thanks the
audience in her regular stammering voice
as the former top 10 girls look at her
in jealousy nano smiles while looking at
shampoo suggesting that this had been
her plan the entire time
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching